You know, September is here,
and for, you know a chunk
of our audience that means
back to school.
So actually, Andy and I had an idea,
we thought it would be a nice gesture,
if we went and visited
some college freshmen,
and help them get
acclimated to college life.
But it's exactly right
cause both you and I
went to college, you graduated I didn't.
(audience laughing)
But we both know how difficult
it is, to be a freshman.
So we thought we bring the
kids some gifts you know,
just get them acclimated.
Let them feel a little more at home.
Exactamundo right, we brought
a crew with some surprises
up to Marist College in
Poughkeepsie New York,
and we paid a surprise
visit to some of their dorms
we just wanted to get them
started off on the right foot.
Right
We thought it was a
really nice thing to do.
Check it out see if you agree.
All right basically, here's the idea.
Andy and I have brought our
college acclimation team, CAT
We got our guys right out here, guys!
come on in here we got some
great stuff that's gonna really
help you adjust to college.
Here we go right here look at this
just you know some munchie stuff.
[Boy] Yes there is a guarded
fluff! Fluff!
[Boy 2] Fluff in order (murmurs)
Here you go guys,
(audience laughing)
this is gonna make your
room the coolest room
Yeah!
Are you doing the Macarena in there?
Oh, yeah I am
Faster
♪ Hey macarena ♪
(audience laughing)
We sitting here with?
Tom Barbera
Tom Barbera, very cool
and you just a this you're
What are you a freshman?
I'm a freshman this my second day.
Second day how's it going so far?
It's good
having lots of fun
(indistinctive chatting)
that matters.
Come on you can be honest with us.
That sucks.
(audience laughing)
You're homesick?
Yeah
we've been--
Why don't you just let it all out.
It's the only way to get rid of it.
I hate it,
(audience laughing)
I miss been at home
Whereas home for you?
South side of New York.
Okay, we're putting them in a van
and we're taking you back
right now and you're gonna work
at the local dry goods store at home okay,
That's good, I mean,
who needs an education?
Thank you that's what
we want to get out there
to the kids.
What are you here to study?
Business Management.
Business Management, that's
not what you want to study
or is it?
No.
What do you want to study?
Sex Ed
Sex Ed?
Your parents won't let you?
No
what does your dad do?
His lawyer
Is he really tough lawyer?
Kind of
Does he have a paneled study
when he wants to talk to you
does he say son see me in the study?
Yeah.
And when he calls you, son,
do you think that it may be
because he doesn't know your name?
(audience laughing)
Some way
You ever said to your dad,
dad! I need a little space?
Have you ever said old
man, you're choking me?
Have you ever attempted suicide?
We found the President's
itinerary in your desk.
What's that all about?
I'm not gonna say anything about that.
You're very strange man, you know that?
Well, there's one thing
that I think could really,
help you acclimate better
to college, a certain skill
that I think you're gonna need to know.
This is a Barbasol shaving cream.
This is a church key can opener.
You take the Pierce point.
This is gonna get your aggression out.
You come in somebody in the shower,
it doesn't really matter
who, tear the curtain back.
Hook the church on, pop the bottom
(beep sound)
(audience laughing)
problem is probably barbasol shaving cream
and the idea is to sneak into
here, into the shower room
with Barbasol and a church key can opener.
Now what you do is when
someone in the shower,
this will help you work out
some of that aggression.
Someone's in the shower, you pull it back,
you take the pears point
and then you go
well,
We trynna
(audience laughing)
make people more comfortable,
you know some of the freshman
cause Andy and I we were
freshmen in college,
no one made the effort
it was very scarring.
So here we go, we got a can of
nature's finest Artichoke Hearts
She likes it
Aw, thanks
You're welcome or how about
some jumbo Ripe Olives
Oh my god is it black
one or the um green ones?
Just Jumbo Ripe Olives
(audience laughing)
Got down let's get these in here,
you guys like, this is
Gefilte Fish right here
and that's in a Jelled Broth
when you hang on to that
Thanks, thank you.
(audience applauding)
Tom when this done you
push the curtain back
it will stand there for all that.
Like there see?
Hah, who's the fool now.
(audience laughing)
We got some stuff basically.
Yeah.
That we are bringing to college students
to make their lives a little better,
we got some Gefilte Fish, Cheese Sauce,
that's Hose right.
There some fancy misspelling.
This is a lamp that Andy
made in the eighth grade
Isn't lamp just said
no one feels left out.
Yeah there's another lamp
Okay let's get that stuff in here,
we're on a tight schedule.
Okay.
There's more hose right here,
this is the bag of popcorn.
Eat that and look happy.
Come on, there you go is one moment time.
[Man] King size mattress right here
because your bed probably not gonna--
That's king size mattress right here,
we just gonna jump on your bed okay.
Come on guys lets go
Here I gotta pet for you
We'll just leave that somewhere here okay.
Yeah just needed some under the bed.
We got a popcorn machine for you here.
Isn't that great?
Have some popcorn while you're at it.
Here you have some popcorn here.
I'm just gonna put the snake here.
Yeah, we'll just put the snake there on
This is a good place.
And we really got to run
but thank you very much.
And we hope you guys have a nice...
and just feed this thing.
It needs a live rabbit
once every hour okay,
(audience laughing)
Okay
Gotta go see you ladies later
Thank you
Watch this step back
look at that
see you get some real
distance out of it that way.
You guys used Zeppelin?
Yeah
Can we give you this Led Zeppelin poster?
Thank you
So Tom while we're getting
the next can ready,
is there anybody that you've met?
You only been here a day but
is there anyone you've met
so far that really kinda ticked you off?
Well, there is one guy.
Thomas fire away
Let's go Thomas is your
turn is your day lets go
Okay, what me to fire?
Yeah.
(audience applauding)
How's a joke right now
It really feels good
Let me talk to you seriously for a second
has a guy ever tried it
on you done this thing?
Around the arm
And then yeah, never tried that.
No they haven't
Okay, because if someone
does do that to you,
give me a call and I'll come up here
I'll teach him a lesson all right.
All right that's a great treat
That's what I do here--
And you can hook me up
could even be better.
Hook you up?
You wanna get hooked up.
Yes, it'd be great.
What kind of guy are you looking for?
I'm a romantic guy, yeah.
Someone's smart and romantic.
Smart and romantic
Okay, well we'll be around all day.
I'm gonna find someone
if we find someone can
we send him back to you?
Sure, that's 512,
Room 512?
Okay, you wanna hurry
or anything (giggling)
No
I'm down
(door banging)
(audience clapping)
Getting pretty crowded out
there, where the students were
talking to us and everything so,
It's getting a little close.
Yeah, so we decided to go
someplace where we knew
we wouldn't bump into any students.
The library (laughing)
Did you like that joke?
Yeah you good
(laughing)
Oh my god (giggling)
Lets go
(laughing)
(door banging) (audience clapping)
(all clapping)
What a better sweet ending
Oh it really meant a sad note
He's fine
Yeah
They later hooked up
We love you Tom
(laughing)
Poor Tom everyone feels bad for him now.
Well that's what he gets for
playing along with our crap.
(laughing)